here we are at Wien Hall Wien Hall is
home to mathematical sciences physics
some undergraduate computer science as
well as material science and engineering
right where I'm standing is the main
entrance to Wien Hall but it's also the
entrance to the fifth floor which is one
of eight floors we also has some other
interesting aspects right above us
there's a lecture hall and over on the
right where there are flow panes of
glass is the engineering and science
library on the fourth floor also on the
fourth floor there's a skyway bridge
that goes over to Newell Simon Hall
which is where we have a lot of our
other technical studies hey if you're in
need of a quick coffee fix check out la
prima espresso in ween hall one of
Pittsburgh's best local coffee shops